là où tu es 17 tournant qui part de nos
pierres pour rallier saint forget est à
nouveau accessible fermer totalement à
la circulation depuis le 23 juillet elle
a fait peau neuve
pendant trois mois ça changeait
complètement les habitudes des gens ça
leur a donné des obligés de faire des
détours de prendre des précautions de
prendre du temps pour les enfants à
l'école pour plein de choses donc été le
témoin des travaux très importants pour
une conne et pourtant ça forge et un
effondrement du talent il y a deux ans a
ajouté un affaissement en rez de
chaussée dans la côte des dix sept
tournant ont rendu indispensable les
travaux le département a injecté 400
mille euros pour permettre à la commune
de saint fort g tech il y avait cinq
mille véhicules par jour qui empruntent
cet axe
c'est un chantier qu une commune seule
la petite commune de saint forget et
c'est un peu plus de 500 habitants
n'auraient jamais pu financer n'aurait
jamais une ingénierie suffisante pour
réaliser ce chantier dont qu'ils avaient
besoin du département deux entreprises
du groupe vinci ont collaboré pour
assurer une consolidation de la chaussée
à l'aide de pioches aurait eu trois
phases une première phase pour faire des
petits travaux préparatoires avant
l'intervention d'entreprises bottes qui
a réalisé les pieux et a pas une fois
qu'ils ont réalisé les pubs on est
revenu pour faire tout le terrassement
de la chaussée une route où tu n'avais
désormais prête à accueillir les
automobilistes qui pour mme au passage
observer une décoration surprise